in this extremely gloomy ominous speech  with the red and the screaming he almost  slips into a prussian accent while he's  giving it he says that we need to be  optimistic even in this moment  with all the challenges we face  i give you my word as abide and i've  never been more optimistic about  america's future not because it may be  because of who you are  we're going to end cancer as we know it  mark my words after this doom and gloom  fire and brimstone we are going to come  for you our political opponent's speech  he says but we need to be  optimistic and as he says optimistic  right on cue you hear a siren in the  background  because  because the very structure of reality  will not tolerate that kind of  preposterous disingenuous hypocritical  lie from joe biden doom and gloom and  pessimism but we need to be optimistic  i don't things aren't looking too  optimistic joe whoo